digamos que tenemos una función
exponencial hdn y como es una función
exponencial sería de la forma amp por
ere elevado a la n donde a es nuestro
valor inicial iebem es nuestra razón
común y vamos a suponer que r es más
grande que 0 además nos dieron algo de
información acerca de hdn esta tabla que
tenemos aquí sabemos que cuando n vale 2
hd 2 144 también sabemos que h t4 es 324
y que h de 6 729 entonces con base en
esta información lo que quiero averiguar
es cuánto vale a y cuánto va a leer y
como siempre te encargo que pausa el
vídeo y vea si puedes resolverlo por ti
mismo ok vamos a hacer esto juntos y
primero me voy a enfocar en r es decir
nuestra razón común nuestra razón común
y bueno si tuviéramos n sucesivas es
decir si tuviéramos ht3 en su dado caso
h de 5
sería mucho más fácil poder encontrar la
razón porque la r saldría de la división
entre h de 3h de 2 o bien si tuviéramos
h de 3h de 4 la razón saldría de la
división de h de 4 entre h de 3 y eso
nos ayudaría para resolver
explícitamente el valor de r pero bueno
simplemente lo que vamos a hacer es
encontrar la razón de h de 4 / h de dos
así que vamos a hacerlo me voy a tomar h
de 4h de 4 / hd2 y voy a encontrar la
razón de esto y bueno esto es lo mismo
que en hd 4 sabemos que vale 324 324
esto es dividido a su vez entre 144 144
muy bien y cuantos esto bueno podemos
simplificarlo un poco 324 esto tiene
mitad cuales la mitad de esto bueno es
262 144 también tiene mitad que es 72
muy bien
ambos tienen mitad también así que lo
voy a hacer de una vez la mitad de 162
es 81 y la mitad de 72 es 36 muy bien
ahora 81 y 36 no tienen mitad pero
tienen novena entonces voy a sacar las
90 de 81 lo cual es 9 y voy a sacar la
novena de 36 que es 4 por lo tanto h t4
entre hd2 es lo mismo que nueve cuartos
bien ahora bien también podemos
reescribir hd 4 y hd 2 utilizando la
función exponencial y que me va a quedar
bueno observar lo siguiente h t4 es lo
mismo que am por ere elevado a la
potencia 4 así que lo voy a poner aquí
por rm elevado a la potencia 4 y cuánto
es h 2 bueno me va a quedar a por el
elevado al cuadrado
por r elevado al cuadrado y con esto me
va a quedar una ecuación muy sencilla
porque estas dos se cancelan me va a
quedar simple y sencillamente r elevado
a la cuarta potencia entre r elevado al
cuadrado esto es lo mismo que r elevado
a la 4 menos 2 o dicho tal manera ere
cuadrada y observa que aquí ya tenemos
una ecuación bastante simple y sencilla
de resolver así que déjame escribirla de
nuevo aquí abajo y tengo re cuadrada es
igual a nueve cuartos nueve cuartos y
cómo queremos que r sea mayor de cero
entonces nos vamos a tomar la raíz
principal de nueve cuartos y me va a
quedar que eren va a ser igual a la raíz
principal de 9
cuartos y bueno sabemos que esta raíz
principal es lo mismo que 3
medios estás de acuerdo así que está de
lujo ya pudimos encontrar el valor de r
ahora como podemos encontrar el valor de
a bueno hay varias maneras de hacerlo
la primera la primera que se me ocurre
es pensar que am es el valor de hd 0 así
que vamos a hacer aquí lo que creo que
podemos llamar un método tabular porque
para esto vamos a construir una pequeña
tabla déjame hacer una pequeña tabla por
aquí una pequeña tabla por aquí ahora
kim ok por aquí tengo a n otra vez y
aquí tengo a hdn y bueno nosotros no
sabemos cuánto vale h de cero lo que
sabemos es que h de cero es igual a pero
bueno no voy a poner nada aquí todavía
tampoco sabemos cuánto vale h de uno
pero lo que sí sabemos es cuánto vale
hd2 hd2 es 144 estás de acuerdo
144 muy bien
voy a usar la idea de que ya sabemos r
la razón común porque recuerda que para
llegar a hd2 tuvimos que multiplicar a h
de uno por la razón y la razón sabemos
que es tres medios así que multiplicamos
por tres medios ahora bien si tenemos a
hd 0 ya sh de 0 lo multiplicamos por
tres medios obtendremos h de uno así que
entonces sí tenemos h de uno y lo
multiplicamos por tres medios obtenemos
hd2 o de otra manera h de uno déjame
escribirlo aquí h de uno va a ser igual
a hd2 dividido entre tres medios así que
me va a quedar 144 entre tres medios o
bueno esto es exactamente lo mismo que
bueno 144 que multiplica
tercios y veamos 144 entre 3 144 entre 3
kv ok mi cerebro no funciona muy bien
cuando hago vídeos así que déjame
hacerlo por aquí me voy a tomar esta
división y dice 3 cabe cuatro veces en
14 4 por 3 es 12 así que le voy a quitar
aquí 12 y bueno me quedan 2 y bajos de 4
y después digo 8 por 3 es 24 así que 8
por 3 es 24 y me queda un residuo de
cero así que 144 entre 3 me quedó 48 y
48 por 2
es lo mismo que 96 de lujo hd 1 es 96 y
para obtener h de 0 lo que hay que hacer
es dividir otra vez 96 entre tres medios
déjame ponerlo aquí ht 0 va a ser lo
mismo que 96 entre
qué bueno es lo mismo que 96 por dos
tercios y bueno veamos 96 entre 3 eso es
lo mismo que 32 32 y 32 por 2
es lo mismo que 64 de lujo h de 0 es 64
y justo así obtuvimos el valor de amd
así que ya podemos sustituir a vale 64
64 r vale tres medios déjame ponerlo por
aquí vale tres medios y bueno esto
elevado a la potencia en déjame
escribiendo aquí ahora sí puedo decir
que hdn hdn es lo mismo que bueno 64 lo
voy a poner con este mismo color 64 que
multiplican a tres medios a tres
medios esto elevado a la potencia en
ahora bien aunque ya llegamos la
respuesta correcta quiero decirte que
había otro método para obtener el valor
de amd así que vamos a ver lo otro
método para obtener el valor de amd es
el siguiente imagínate que yo me tomo un
hd 2 lo voy a poner aquí tengo el valor
de hd 2 y sabemos que hd 2 si
sustituimos justo aquí obtengo anp que
multiplica a la razón pero la razón ya
la sabíamos que era 3 medios esto
elevado al cuadrado y bueno esto es lo
mismo que sabemos que hd 2 es 144 144
muy bien y si ahora elevó esto el
cuadrado voy a obtener que am que
multiplica a nueve cuartos esto debe de
ser igual a 144 y bueno si ahora
multiplico de ambos lados por el
recíproco de nueve cuartos es decir
cuatro novenos 492
por cuatro novenos bueno déjame bajar un
poco la pantalla esto me va a quedar
esto me va a quedar este con este se va
a este con este se van y me queda simple
y sencillamente que am es igual a am y
cuantos esto bueno 144 entre 9 144 entre
99 cabe una vez en 14 y sobran 5 54
estos 16 16 estás de acuerdo
16 x 4 es 64 y de lujo llegamos de nuevo
al mismo valor de a esta es otra forma
de verlo sin usar este método tabular y
bueno ahora que lo veo creo que es un
método un poco más sencillo que este
método tabular pero lo que quiero que
veas es que son métodos equivalentes y
me gusta un poco más este es el método
tabular porque puedes ver a la razón
común en acción y puedes ver que llegas
al valor inicial y ese valor inicial es
h de cero pero de cualquier manera una
vez que obtienes a r y sabes el valor de
la función para una cierta n entonces
puedes resolver fácilmente para
y también pasa que si conoces y sabes el
valor para una cierta n entonces de la
misma manera puedes obtener el valor de
r en fin espero que todo esto lo hayas
disfrutado bastante